Hello, everybody.
Welcome to the Active Inference
Lab today.
It's October 22nd 2021
and it's ActInfLab Gueststream
number 11.1.
I'm Daniel.
I'm here with Bleu and our guest Greg.
So Greg,
thank you so much for being here.
And please introduce yourself
and take it away.
We'll be monitoring the live chat.
So if you have any questions
during the presentation, please
feel free to ask them
and we'll talk about them at the end.
But otherwise, thanks again for being
here and looking forward to this event.
Wonderful.
Hey, it's a real honor to be here.
I've seen a couple of other presentations
are really fascinating.
I look forward to sharing
some of my version of reality.
So let me give you a little bit
of orienting coordinates for me.
So I am Professor in the Combined
Integrated
Clinical and School Doctoral Program
at James Madison University.
Where I've been since 2003.
The role
I function there is to train individuals
to be
psychological doctors is the term we use.
The reason we use that is because
in psychology, in the profession
side, there are different practice areas,
clinical counseling and school
are the dominant practice areas.
But we want to transcend those
into a more general combined integrated
perspective that affords us a way
to kind of get out of some of the old
traditional institutional silos and
get a more general integrated picture.
So I've been there since 2003.
My journey in this is
I went to undergrad, got my major
in psychology and was just going to be
a behavioral scientist
that wanted to be a clinician.
My sense was the right thing to do
was to apply the methods
and findings of science
to the clinical world.
I went off, got my masters in clinical
and community psychology
in 1994 and
well well
why don't I
go ahead and start the presentation
and then I'll walk you through some
of that history
and then we'll get to the scenario
where ultimately you get this
weird cartoon of a garden on behind me
and we'll get to there over a period
and then we'll start into
what we're actually dealing with.
So make sure my screen here
so so we're talking about
the ontology of mental behavior and
just going to give it a context
my basic point
for defining this talk
is then to be in contrast
to the current mainstream approach
in academic psychology.
The mainstream approach
in academic psychology is really best
frame is what I would call
methodological behaviorism.
Methodological Behaviorism,
a term by Jane Moore.
But all it means is basically what is
psychology in the academy right now?
Is that it applies
the methods of behavioral science
to a thing very vaguely
defined as behavior
and mental process. OK,
and indeed,
the methods of science really are
what end up defining the term behavior,
which is the shit
you can see from our science perspective.
OK, and then the mental processes
are sort of the stuff
that's inferred
that give rise to the change in behavior,
at least if you're a mentalist
or a cognitive test
in traditional psychology as opposed
to, say, a radical behaviorist.
OK, so the science of psychology
is really defined
by an institution
that applies methods of science,
methods of behavioral science
in particular to analyze behavior
and then develop models of mental process
that are for the explanation
now the structure of it is broken
at the level of coherence.
And what I mean by that
is it doesn't there's
no organizing framework for psychology
psychology is not
defined by
and never has been defined by a paradigm
meaning a full in a cooney
in sense paradigm meaning a full
like Newton developed a paradigm
for classical mechanics
that then established psychology
that is a is a field
that had lots of different schools
of thought mini paradigms
that tried to manifest itself
as sort of the dominant paradigm.
That didn't happen.
There were no dominant paradigms
in psychology.
It gave rise to
what's called the crisis in psychology
that led Vygotsky specifies in 1927.
So we're talking
now over almost 100 years ago
in fact it was at first identified
in 1899 a crisis
in psychology
then just punts on the issue.
It's like, what do you,
what do you mean by that.
What's the field subject matter.
And the answer is
well different schools of thought
will frame that in different ways. OK,
the ontology of
mental behavior is the argument
that actually we can do better than that.
We don't have to define the field
based on epistemology, i.e.
the methods of science,
but we actually can define the field
based on a scientific ontology
that clarifies
what is meant by mental behavior.
And in so doing it affords a coherent
solution to the problem of psychology.
So the problem of psychology
is the inability of the field to cohere
around a particular conception
of its subject matter.
So that's the basic structure.
I'm like I said, I'm
at James Madison combined integrated.
So what's the basic
just just to get a lay of the landscape
from where I'm coming from.
And I'm, you know, I'm an odd bird.
So you should be very clear
that I I'll be doing a weird version
of psychology now for for a long time,
I started to say this.
I entered into the field
sort of in a conventional sense.
I got trained in the normal methods
of behavioral science
and analysis of variance and,
and all that good stuff and was like,
oh, well, clearly we want to employ
a standard empirical method to delineate
you know, what the sort of the truth is
or the most accurate models.
And so but then I encountered this thing
called the problem of psychotherapy
what's that?
We actually get into the room
with people, and that's a trick.
And then you're a real person
in a real situation
in the idiosyncratic processes
by which you have to make active
inferences about what is
operating in the moment. OK,
means
that a generalized aggregate
variable analysis
so that the rest of the field does like,
oh, here's a problem.
It's called major depressive disorder.
Here's a specific specified intervention
called cognitive therapy.
And now you're to imply this cognitive
therapy intervention with this person.
Sorry, but what I learned
and I didn't know it at the time,
but what I learned
was the level of abstraction
at the variable aggregate level
relative to the actual process
by which you engage
in feedback in the room,
in a participatory, real relationship
of course, I have language for this
now that I didn't have then,
but the bottom line was that, you know,
what I actually saw in the field
was that the best of the best,
depending
on regardless of the school of thought,
the best of the best
did the best, surprisingly enough.
And lousy players from various
all the different schools did lousy
and most people did average.
And the schools of thought really don't
generate
systematic difference,
at least of bonafide schools of thought.
So essentially
what you get in psychotherapy is the
what's called the dodo bird finding.
I'm president
elect of the Society for the Exploration
of Psychotherapy integration,
which is a field that has long
standing questions in relationship
to the relationship
between the schools of thought
and and I got then introduced in 1994.
This is basically to the field through
a potentially integrative perspective. So
for me that was fascinating.
It turns out that my orientation
is actually what's called a big picture
coherent test orientation, meaning
that I actually want to zoom the way
to organize pieces in a particular way
so that I can create a coherent
frame of reference and then zoom back in
with the coherent frame of reference.
That's the way my mind operates.
So I had zoomed out and then realized
that there is actually no coherence
at the level of psychotherapy, and people
have known this for a long time.
And then this whole field that emerged
in the mid 1980s, this was like
15 years ten years down the road
from that emergence of that field
with the psychotherapy
integration problem.
And then I was fascinated by it
and I did something
that's actually no one's ever done,
which is kind of interesting.
I looked at medicine
and this is just all intuitive.
and I said, you know,
you don't have all these different
schools of thought and medicine.
It's not like you have, you know,
the cardiologists are not battling with
the endocrinologist versus, you know,
the people that emphasize the gut.
You know, they all are like,
hey, there are different systems
of biological adaptation that function
together in a whole and thing.
We have a thing called human biology
human biology
is the science
that organizes the various domains
and that affords a descriptive
explanatory framework that then should
inform the practice of medicine.
So if we jump up a level,
it seems reasonable to me
or it seemed intuitively reasonable to me
that there should be a human science
of human psychology that should organize
the descriptive explanatory
network of understanding, OK?
And then apply that to the field
all right.
So now notice what I had done.
I got socialized into the empirical
methodological behavioral science
approach of psychology,
dropped into the problem
of psychotherapy backed up
and was like, Oh, wait a minute.
What I really need as a practitioner is
I need a holistic conception
of human psychology
that affords clarity about what the hell
the field is actually talking about.
Sorry, I'll probably drop an F bomb here
or there if that's OK.
But anyway, what I basically realized
then here is I shifted perspective
and I said, Well, what is psychology?
And then I realized, Oh my God,
nobody knows what the fuck psychology is.
There's no word that
everyone's got different reference points
for this fundamental work, OK?
And that's the problem of psychology.
There's a dramatic set of reference
points that.
And so I then took a couple of left
turns that I can tell you about in 1996
and then a big one in 1997, and all of
a sudden I actually developed a vision,
not like some transcendent vision
although it has these elements.
I developed a picture,
an organizing picture,
really a new map of big history,
as it were, that afforded me
a new way to address this problem
of what psychology is, OK?
And that ultimately gives rise
to a clear ontology of the mental.
All right, we'll specify
what I mean by that and then by affording
clarity about what the scientific
conception of the mental is.
I could then organize my work,
then return to the original problem
and develop
a framework for psychotherapy.
And so that's what the project is about.
Now, my journey over this time period
basically is the first thing is, Hey,
there's a problem. And I need this.
And then I built this thing
called the Tree of Knowledge System.
The Tree of Knowledge System
is this natural scientific ontology
that maps the world in a particular way
that affords a science
of a natural science
view of what the mental is.
I worked
on that and said, Hey, it organizes
the field.
I did.
You know, I can tell
about my publication, history, et cetera.
And then ultimately that evolved in
what's called the Unified
Theory of psychology.
The Unified Theory of Psychology
specifies the tree of knowledge
and then a couple of other key ideas
that then provide
a conceptual architecture
for assimilating.
And then in writing the schools
of thought
and major empirical findings
into a coherent whole.
So again,
it provides a conceptual architecture
for assimilating
and integrating the schools of thought
and the major, major schools of thought
and major empirical findings
to afford a coherent
whole of the picture.
And basically then create a new unified
theory of psychology
I then shifted that I did that,
but published that in 2011.
I then returned to the original problem
and from 2011 2016 or so worked out
been given this framework.
What would a unified approach
to psychotherapy be?
Well,
and I don't delineated four key ideas
that could help organize the field
and generate
a unified approach to psychotherapy,
at least with individual adults.
OK, child's are different blah blah blah
I was honed in on sort of standard
individual psychotherapy, especially
for neurotic adults, which are the vast
majority people come in for psychotherapy
or neurotic adults.
So this affords then a one of a way
to organize the key insights and then and
so then you would have a unified theory
of psychology and a unified approach OK
well then in 2016, as I was delineating
that I took another weird turn.
All right.
And there are a lot of reasons as to why
but the short story is I was
I was at a conference called
Cultivating the Globally Sustainable Self
about transformative education
and the massive global problems
that we face in relation.
And it was in the context
of that conference.
I had created this model
the unified theory and unified approach
and was called a 21.
OK, let's
I just dropped into the language.
You know, things were get more
and more efficient,
you know, as you teed up on a tour.
So I'm just like you total.
I was like,
wow, let's do that, blah, blah, blah.
So I'm at this conference
and they're doing this
talking
fundamentally about how to do this thing
called cultivate
a globally sustainable self, meaning
how do we transform our education
for children in the rural world
that we're in given all the crises
and challenges that we face,
what does that actually look like?
And fast conference.
And at the end of it,
there was a panel discussion
and panel discussion actually got
all the people they invited there
and they came up
and they actually all fumbled over
the question as far as I was concerned.
Like they were brilliant people.
They did this.
They couldn't
actually there was a summary opportunity.
I left the conference
and I was walking away
and I was talking to somebody else, like,
you know what we should do?
We should plant a two
a seeds and grow it to a tree,
which sort
of fell out of me as a light bulb moment
and then turned into the thing behind me,
which is this garden.
And all of a sudden
I basically then transform this build
this construction that I had
with all these different
sort of like a cathedral
that I got transformed into a garden.
I actually then got called
into like spiritually, artistically
to build this garden
so that now this knowledge system
then can be represented
symbolically in a garden.
And that's what's by me.
So it's a it's a layer knowledge system
sort of like, for example.
Well, just so that's,
that's, that's and then, you know,
I got pulled more into that
and then that shifted me further
and further into the orbit of weirdness.
All right.
But anyway, that's
basically what I realized fundamentally
is why I got pulled into this
level of abstraction was something
that I sort of got clearer on
as I've been writing my current book.
And that is a real understanding
fundamentally
of what's going on here in relationship
to kind of our knowledge system.
So we have a foundational problem
in our knowledge and what I call
this foundational problems
called the Enlightenment gap.
What the hell is that?
The Enlightenment gap
is the point that when science emerged
came in from Galileo and Newton
coming off of the scholastics
when we built physical science
and the epistemology
and ontology
that emerged with physical science,
that was never of ability to take what
we learned from the physical sciences
and create a holistic, synthetic
philosophy.
Conte tried, Hegel tried, et cetera.
But what you basically get in
the Enlightenment is a gap a failure
to get the proper
relationships first on the relationship
between matter and mind.
OK, some based body problem.
What the hell is that?
How do you actually solve that?
And then the other thing emerges
as a secondary or joint problem is
what is actual scientific knowledge
relative to social knowledge, OK?
And this problem emerges.
We see in the 20th century
with the emergence
of the philosophical postmodern
critique of modernity,
which basically says,
hey, modernity made too many abstract
pure, reasoned progress, claims
that they were actually
that you could find genuine truth
that's not contextualized
in a socio historical justification
context.
Of the postmodern critique.
And actually you can't really make
knowledge claims that are transcendent.
They're all imminently contextualized
in the socio historical context.
And Lo and behold, look at the way
the knowledge systems emerge.
They privileged cisgendered, white
colonial men who go around and create
oh yes, this history of reason and bobble
behold is actually normative
for us and we get to distribute
our power structures around the world.
And so you've got a philosophical
and a social justice postmodern critique
about what science says
relative to social knowledge.
That never actually gets resolved.
OK, and that's why we have postmodern
versus modern
anto epistemological debates
about the nature of knowledge.
And so the Enlightenment gap
basically is a description
of the current state of affairs
where we have
we're lacking a philosophical framework
that affords us clarity
about matter in mind.
On the one hand, and science
and social knowledge on the other.
OK, so that's the gist of the
location about where we are.
I built this
thing called the Unified
Theory of Knowledge.
What is unified?
Unified is taken directly from the book
Conciliate the Unity of Knowledge. E.O.
Wilson wrote a book called Consilience
in 1998 called The Consultants
The Unity of Knowledge.
That's what unified means.
I means conciliate.
There's a conciliate coherence,
big picture view that actually
gets the pieces of the puzzle correct.
So we actually understand
knowing and knowing how we know
and knowing what we mean
when we know things physically
and what we know things biologically,
what we actually mean psychologically,
human psychologically
into the social sciences,
how we know scientifically relative to
how do we know subjective
what do we know about ethics, et cetera.
There's actually a coherent synthetic
philosophy that is available
that frames these problems
that wasn't achievable before
and so here's the garden crime.
And what it has here is so for example,
right here,
this little thing is called
the stepping stone.
What is that step stands for?
The Standard Theory of elementary
particle physics and the stepping stone.
Then grounds
you in physics in a particular way.
Then this first branch is the tree
of knowledge system, the base of
which is the energy information
quantum field structures
that live underneath matter
and go back to Big Bang.
And then each one of these
is a layered system of information
processing called life, mind and culture.
And it is that arrangement of energy
information
gives rise to a classic material field,
and then life emerges and then mind.
And I'll explain what I mean by mind here
emerges at the animal, mental,
behavioral level.
And then culture emerges so
that we become go from primates to people
as we talk to each other and build
what are called systems of justification.
So that just gives you a flavor for it.
There's other things
that are going on here
that I won't necessarily get into,
but it basically says
there's actually a knowledge system here.
The left side is the unified theory.
You can see actually there's a little
you here and a T
and these four ideas make up
what's called the unified theory.
There's a U and an A, which stands
for the unified approach.
OK, this right here
is a symbol of mindfulness
on the right side of the branches.
The way in which we relate to people
in healthy psychological ways.
It's actually called calm memo.
It's integrative approach
to psychological mindfulness.
It's the processes by which we can hold
each other and ourselves
and deal with difficult social emotional
relations that are forward, productive,
virtuous looping, as opposed to
what often happens to people is
they get trapped in negative cycles
attack each other and then get in
vicious, destructive looping.
That's just one example.
So the tree
then as eight key ideas, four of which
make up the unified approach
this is, by the way, the tree of Life.
The Tree of knowledge is the first branch
tree of life.
That's for here, for here.
And then as a symbol in the middle,
which is actually called the metaphysical
empirical flower, metaphysical
empirical flower creates a dialectic
between metaphysics and empiricism.
And that was missing in the structure
of the Enlightenment, which we need
is the thing down here called the coin.
But I'll pause here, just plenty of
structure there.
Let me make a few more comments
and then actually I'll pause after this.
So ultimately, what the unified theory
does is it affords a new opportunity
to think about the Enlightenment
gap, and I argue resolve it.
And what it does is it sets the stage
for a unified theory of psychology
and frames
a unified approach to psychotherapy.
OK, so that's basically
then we can get into
what does all this mean in relationship
to some of the deep theory?
But I wanted to give folks an opportunity
for the basic gist of where I'm
coming from.
Thank you for the summary.
Cool work and symbolic images.
So anyone watching
live can definitely write questions
but that's a great place to start.
We got the personal
and the multi-level narrative
coming together with a little bit
of a challenge and a response
which will then learn more about.
So maybe we can just go blue
if you have any comments.
Otherwise we
can go into the next section.
I don't know if we want
to go through some of my questions now.
I mean, I have some that relate to the
Unified Universal Theory of knowledge.
So if we want to maybe pull up that slide
or if Greg is still showing slides,
we don't have to.
I can just read it off the slide.
So the. Perfect.
Yeah, and it's on the screen as well.
So here's one.
Just summary quote
first, the UTI, OK, differentiates
the mental behavior of animals
from the behavior
of other living creatures,
both metaphysically
and better theoretically.
Which you mentioned.
And second, it differentiates
the mental behavior of human persons
from the mental behavior
of other animals, both metaphysically
and better theoretically.
OK, so similar,
but a little bit different there.
So what are the distinctions
that are critical for psychology
what distinctions does your work make?
How do we know those are the right ones?
How did you carve UTI?
OK at the G exaggerates beautiful ok.
So yeah, love that.
That's a wonderful set of questions
and gets right to the heart
of some of the key issues.
OK, so let's talk about the
so the the tree of Knowledge
Divides is a descriptive
metaphysical system.
That's a,
the picture
is an it shows matter
like mind and culture.
OK, so basically coming off Big Bang.
So you start what's called
an energy information singularity.
All right.
That's how you go back to Big Bang,
13.8 billion years ago.
ET cetera.
You free run the tape back and everything
collapses into quote unquote a point
or a singularity
because this is just general cosmology.
All right.
I'm getting to the question,
but I just give this background.
OK, so according to modern cosmology,
the universe essentially begins
in a state of pure energy information.
That's at least what I refer to it as.
We can talk about the term
and then out of that comes matter time.
And basically what you get is
you get all the four fundamental forces
in nature that's electromagnetism,
gravitation, strong,
weak, differentiating to create fields.
And then you get a coalescence,
a cooling in the freezing and coalescence
of energy into chunks of matter
in the form of particles,
atoms up into then chemicals and certain
unique context.
And then across scale that builds
things like stars and galaxies
and mega galaxy clusters.
OK, so this is
then our physical universe.
All right.
And notice what I've done
and the reason I had to say
this is because one of the first things
we have to note from classical mechanics
is that modern physicist physics
teaches us that there's a thing beneath
the classical material world
called quantum
field theory and the energy information
singularity of Big Bang.
The reason that's really important
because we have to understand
the fundamental substance
ontology of the world,
which is energy information fields,
not billiard balls.
OK, so there we're working in the initial
sort of ontology is billiard ball shit.
And it's like, no, that's
actually not the ground of the universe.
Ground of the universe
is sort of like an energy information
superpower horse field theory, right?
Which by the way for mental
and the implications
to understand the way mental structures
work, it's important.
It's some people like Bernardo Castro,
please drop it all the way round.
Call that Big Mind
I don't agree with that.
But fundamentally,
we do want to understand that, OK,
then we come and we jump up.
We don't know how this exactly happens.
What about four or 3.8 billion years ago?
We see the jump in the world
from chemicals, complicated
chemical protein, lipid structures
that somehow jump together organized.
And we get life.
OK, so the miracle of life. All right.
So the miracle of life then creates
the jump from quasi organizing systems
that then get into fundamentally sloping,
into self-organize.
What Deakin Terence Deakin calls
intentional phenomena
that operate across Abstentia.
OK, so intentional phenomena meaning that
basically there is some descriptively
not explanatory, but descriptively
these cells behave with a goddamn purpose
and they're doing it OK,
and it somehow is that they're imagining
that they are black
and then they move toward black
like they're hungry and they go
and they don't want to die
and they move around.
OK. Incomplete Nature is Terrence
Deakins analysis of this jump.
Well, this is really important
to understand the emergence
of complex adaptive dynamic systems
because that's what life is.
It's a complex, adaptive, dynamic system.
That has embedded in it
energy information systems
that are the capacity to pull.
I'll use a slightly different call
for some free energy
from the environment to do work
to maintain its complex organization.
So survives and reproduces.
OK, and the reason I have to tell you
all of that
is because the ground that we need
to understand the dynamic biological
ground out of which then minded
animals are going to emerge from
so so that we get a natural selection
operating on genetic combinations.
And what happens according to unified
theory is actually you get
an orthogonal dimension of activity,
orthogonal to the real in some ways.
What I mean by
that is the subject of information
processing, the epistemic information
processing of a cell is like
the cell is actually making judgments
and quasi even decisions as it engages in
some kind of primitive act of inference
OK. And so then that becomes the ground.
And then basically you get bacteria
that are doing that for a long time
in other kinds of animal kingdom.
I mean, you know, algae, another kinds
of properties kind of kingdom stuff.
And then you get multicellular
plants, OK,
that afford the opportunity
for what big historians call big life
so you get multi cellular plants
and you also are going to get fungi
mycologist study things
like they do really weird stuff.
Fungi
and then you get
so you're going to get these active
multicellular entities
that are still though fundamentally
organized and grounded
and change their environment
through their growth
potentials within the cell.
So even things like mushrooms,
what mushrooms don't do is they don't
get up and walk around.
All right.
But what they do is they send out
growth signals into particular things
and then they grow
in really interesting ways,
but they are confined by their boundaries
all right.
But what happens
is that in the animal kingdom,
there's a shut off in relationship
to this so that this system
now becomes as a multi
organizing system becomes mobile.
All right,
so 700 million years ago,
you're going to get then a transition
into basically jellyfish like creatures
that have distributed neural networks
that have some degree of capacity
for coordinating their behavior.
All right.
Through the distributed neural net
that's the first step towards a mind it
animal.
It's not there yet.
You then get bilateral planning
with an an emerging integration
between the sensory motor structures
OK like in a plenary a worm
now a plenary worms
got a centralized controlled center
a sudden distributing
and it's got bilateral movement
to coordinate its movement
in a particular way.
Now you're very close to the plenary
or worm to what
I would call a minded animal.
The final thing is that you
then get the Cambrian explosion
550, 520 million years ago.
And in this short period of time,
basically you get a much greater
complexity
creation of the nervous system.
You get a centralized nervous system
and you get a complex active body plan.
That complex active body plan
then regulates a sensory motor looping
OK that affords the animal
to get up and move around.
All right.
Now that's a game changer.
It moves the entire structure
as a sensory motor loop.
OK, and it is that division,
that joint point
between life living organisms
and mind it animals
that the tree of knowledge points to
and says, Hey, that Cambrian explosion
thing is when minded animals
blew out of living organisms,
there's a joint point thing
that's as important to understand
in our big picture as the joint point
between non inanimate matter and that.
And it follows a very similar pattern
because what you see like with cells,
what did you get?
You got an RNA DNA information
processing closure
around a lipid with protein generation
that's then creates
a communication network
between other cells.
Well, the nervous system is very much
akin to the RNA.
It's a centralized control system.
And what it does is it knocks all
the cells together in a coordinated way.
So the animal gets to move
as a whole unit.
So the sensory motor
looping of animal movement, that becomes
a fundamental another dimension
of information processing communication.
We get animal animal movement
working with each other
in a communication network,
you get the base of the mind dimension.
OK, so in the unified theory, that's
and you can then it's defined
behaviorally and descriptively.
So it's a complex active body
moving in relationship
to each other with functional outcomes.
That's what it is.
So when you go and you walk your dog,
your dog is exhibiting this,
the insects are exhibiting this, OK?
And it's, it's called mindedness
or mind it's the functional animal,
the behavior as a whole, mediated
by the nervous system, OK?
It produces
a reliable, understandable fact.
The base of this looping,
I see as basic, you know,
predictive processing,
active inference, essential, OK,
there's a fundamental iterative process
that is regulating information, energy
and particular structures
that theory, the matter
theoretical structure I bring to bear
is called behavioral investment theory.
OK, behavioral investment
theory is a meta perspective
that takes together
what's called energy economics.
So you have to solve the problem
of entropy and energy expenditure.
So it's those first principles energy
economics, second is evolution,
the natural by natural selection
and other any other things
we have to add to that.
But that's the general just the third
principles, behavioral genetics,
which means the genetic
the gene system is going to bias
the system in a particular way.
The fourth principle is neuro
computational control.
So neural computational control
then the processes by which we engage
in neural computational control
then is analyzed
deeply by an act of inference
predictive processing.
The fifth principle is learning
and of course then that's how a system
upgrades and relationship to experience
and the six principles life history
development, meaning depending on where
the animal is in its life history.
Is it young?
Is it adolescent,
is it late life, et cetera?
It's reproductive and survival strategies
are going to change based on its life
history development.
So the six principles
of behavioral investment
and what they do
then is they yoked together
neuroscience and evolutionary theory
and computational cognitive.
And by the way, behavioral science
from the vantage point
of a radical behavioral position
like a skinner.
This is actually I come through this
from Skinner, by the way, which is weird.
OK, so so Skinner actually what Skinner
does is he just sits on the outside.
He basically says, oh, it's fucking
black box, it's physiology, black box.
But what I will track is I will track at
a very fine grain analysis consequences,
the animals, what I can do.
And something is got consequences
and it is the consequences that pull
the animal in.
It's behavioral investment
and I can navigate the consequences
as an instrument, as an engineer,
he thinks like an engineer.
He's not thinking like a theorist.
He's really an engineer.
You know, he wanted to be a poet, OK,
but it basically fails.
There's a poet and there's like, what?
Really?
But, you know, I think it really
we can do a psychodynamic interpretation
what happens to him.
But I don't have any structure
focusing on how to control
the consequences
to pull investment from an animal.
And so that's an exterior behavioral
position, and that's radical behaviorism,
which, by the way, is totally different
than mythological ruins.
Various, you know, 5% psychologists go
this applied behavior analysis.
But it's really key because we want to be
able to bring the fact of the matter is
a dynamic control, consequential system
from the outside, behavioral,
outside, is going to connect
to the offer active inference.
So somebody asks a questions like, hey,
can we connect enactment?
And an activism and representational ism
with a behavioral selection structure
like yeah, yeah, you can.
OK, so anyway,
that's behavioral investment theory.
And what that does is
it takes you from basic
the Cambrian explosion and crabs
all the way up and oil everything's
changing, but you can go all the way
up to primates following this line.
And that's the dimension of mindedness.
We can talk about the stack,
but behavioral assessment theory tracks
that stack in the evolution of mind
brain behavior in the animal kingdom,
it's called Mind as a capital
M is really an introduction
of a particular term,
and it's the first joint point
and so what the descriptive metaphysics
and ontology is, oh, here's
the set of mental behavior, the meta
theories, behavioral investment theory,
OK? And that goes then from organisms
into animal mental behavior.
And it's a joint point
that people fail to see too often.
So I'll stop there and say this is
then the ground of mental behavior
is we've set up
and then we'll go all the way up
through the animal kingdom
and then we'll jump into the human
primate to become a person
and what that does.
And then finally
we actually got to come back
and actually talk about the psyche
but not the whole another almost.
So so just to clarify here, like you're
you're presenting two things as central
and kind of required for mind
with the capital
M, and those are mobility
and a central nervous system,
is that correct?
Right.
It's really it's a complex active body
with a central nervous system
that ties up a motor system
in a sensory system together.
There's interesting analysis of evolution
about how you get a sensory system
in a motor system, how do they actually
evolve when they come together.
So when you have an exemplar of a mind
did animal is a complex,
centralized nervous system,
an active body
that produce a functional effect
on the animal environment.
Well, so how do you rectify like things
like people who are paralyzed, are they
then mindless because they're not mobile?
Oh, of course. Not.
So then we need well, dialog. Exactly.
So, so now we're within dialog
about the different domains of mind.
OK, so ultimately
we'll take somebody like
Stephen Hawking OK, so Stephen
Hawking has an entire shell of existence
right
through the mediation of the sensory
motor control system
on the behavioral extension
to Lou Gehrig's disease.
Unplugs that, you know,
what a nightmare, right?
And then you get what he then experiences
what's called mind.
He still has in my language,
we can get to a mind.
One is inside the organism.
The neural computational layering
of the modeling inside
the organism is called mind one, and
that's the neuro computational structure.
OK, if you mind one, a is the inside mind
one, B is the mediated by the sensory
motor looping.
OK, so definitely you
then the entire definition
in the large scale of what the exemplar
is, is the sensory motor loop.
But obviously then what happens is
what's called mind one A
is the neurocognitive infrastructure
within the nervous system,
OK, versus my one B,
which is the actual observable
from the exterior
mediated by the muscle movements.
So what happens is with people
like we get this mind one, B gets X,
OK, but my one, hey,
the architecture is still there.
Now if we now jump up to humans,
they have what's called mind
to like other primates and idea
that we can argue how far it goes mind to
is called subjective conscious
experience of being is first
for the hard problem of consciousness.
The first person experience of being mind
one gives rise to do
we can dialog about this mind to mind
two is available from the inside
subject of conscious experience
and then mind three
is the justifying mind
which other animals don't have,
but humans do ok.
And then we created information interface
with Stephen Hawking
so that he kept after his entire system
got shut down.
Instead of locking him
in, we were able
to create a verbal interface
so we can maintain contact
with this brilliant mind
and he could tell us about, Hey,
actually,
I don't think the information
is lost in black holes
and I can actually even do the analysis,
ok, but if we didn't have that interface,
he would have been lost
but we would have known that, yes,
he would have had mind one a
the insight inferential architecture
mind to the first person
experience of being and mind three
A which is the internal narrator
but he would have lost Mind three
B, which is what I'm doing right
now, talking to you publicly.
But thankfully
we maintain his information interface
and maintain
contact with this great mind.
Thank you, Greg. So
I just wanted to kind of recap two points
and just maybe show
a little point of contact
with what you mentioned
and some of the big themes
in active inference.
So first,
you mentioned how there was these
abstractions and mean field
approximations in the clinical field.
And so that didn't
that was like speaking to a disconnect
between theory and application
and practice
and making impact on the systems
that people care about.
And then also to the more deeper
physical question
about mean field approximations
and whether you can study
like the trajectory of one particle
versus just take the time average,
the space average, we're not going to go
into the whole Ergodic city
non equilibrium
steady state definition, but
those are key terms for active inference.
So they come into play with that
inference like.
I am, I am, I don't have mastery,
I am a non
the active inference
meaning of a lot of those terms.
So I need to get I need to be brought up
to speed on some of that.
But it's exactly that.
If someone says, well, you know
the machine in the mean field it works.
But what if one in a hundred failed
catastrophically then is that an approach
that works, for example?
So if she never come up in some machine
learning context.
So that was kind of a cool
showing how the idea of the part
particular trajectory versus
the mean field
and how that plays out in the way that
our knowledge and application systems,
health care systems are constructed,
which is an initial modification
through us.
And then
so then the second one was like that
combination of appeal
to general frameworks universals
and the historical trajectory
of the whole horizon of life on Earth.
And of course our developmental
trajectory as psychological individuals.
So then it's like, well, that looks goal
oriented a lot.
I thought goal orientation
had to be purged.
Well,
I mean, the first easy answer is just
that was a period of disinformation
and that that stance is simply incorrect.
So that's one way to simplify the debate.
But then the other maybe longer answer,
you said
it's energy information fields,
not billiards.
So we don't appeal to anything
when we see diffusion and ink diffusing.
Now that's kind of slam dunk,
but are there diffusion processes
for metabolism
strategy, narrative communication.
So why don't we need anything more
to just allow those flows to also happen?
And so in academic, we talk a lot
about those types of models as well.
So certainly a lot of cool areas.
Nice first section.
Yeah, no.
OK, so the tree of knowledge is both
continuous so allows for full deflation
on the one hand
or reductive continuity
into energy information on the one hand.
And then if you look at it, it's
actually discontinuous dramatically so
in its funnels
so matter like mind and culture.
And so there's a profound
discontinuity as well.
And it is the process
by which if we really want to get
at this, it's the process
by understanding this very complicated
dynamic of continuity and discontinuity
and that the unified theory affords
a particular way
to understand the discontinuity of matter
out of energy, life, out of matter,
mind out of life and culture out of mind.
And so yeah,
but the real reason when I heard course,
you know, especially free energy stuff,
although I still am trying to wrap
my head around all the terminology,
I haven't devoted myself
to really uncovering it.
OK, but the tree of knowledge basically
is a depiction of neg entropic curvature.
OK, and then the question
is how does a system pull
how do the
tracking forms that actually function,
subtract forms and make predictions?
And it's got to create anticipatory
structures that both navigate
the dialectic of stability and plasticity
to pull free energy into the structure.
And I use that term more in a Aizen way.
He's a cosmic evolutionary biologist,
I mean cosmologist and talks
about the evolution of mega entropy
through a free energy principle.
And because I learned that first
and then I was I've been entangled some
with some of the confusion on at least
classic call, for instance, free energy.
But anyway, it's, it's very close.
I mean, I just I'm sure
it's just a technical set of terms
I need to download to be clear about.
Well,
we and many others,
including anyone who listens to this
are part of the sense making and we're
working on a participatory ontology.
There's a lot more to say.
But let me just
give one free energy answer
and then maybe let's dove
back to a presentation of yours. Yep.
So to return to this idea of energy
and information fields being primary,
not billiards.
So in a world where matter, energy is
heterogeneous easily distributed,
some as in stars, some as in interstellar
space or whatever systems
that resist dissipation,
what we use the blanket terminology
to discuss smart blanket systems
that reduce dissipation and have a non
death equilibrium stationary state.
Those systems are at least acting
as if they're trying,
which in complex symbolic ecosystems
means anticipatory predictive behavior
anticipatory predictive signaling.
And therefore it's helpful
to have a action loop
model perception,
cognition, action, niche impact.
It's helpful to have that type of model
which is in the pre active inference
work of Carl Forrest and others.
Also Central, the dynamical equations
and stochastic simulations
and things like that.
So there's a lot to say,
but that we all hope to be resolving
that uncertainty that comes up.
Great.
I'll pop in where I'm coming from
on this real first lecture screen.
Go to a different awesome.
There's a I think I need to go.
You're all alone one second
because I wanted to pull this up.
Ah, and
did I.
Maybe I'd closed it.
Oh well
yeah.
I'll take a second here. One second.
Let me just look at this.
Oh sure.
I ended up with here
OK, sure.
Reset your priors. Yeah,
well,
this is more complicated than normal.
Let me see if I got it right here.
OK, I go here and.
One other short
thought while you're OK, go for it.
And I'm going to close that down
one second.
I'm sorry. Oh, yeah. Take your time.
Just one other short.
Dark blue
do you want to do anything first?
OK, chin Bergen's questions.
So part of a pluralistic approach
towards understanding includes
mechanistic and historical answers.
And so the way that you situated this
in the sort of ecological critique
and the socio ecological critique,
the relativist
and not just like nihilist,
like relativist, things are relational.
It's interactions all the way down
rather than particles all the way down.
So that
and the dialectical tradition as well.
So many interesting threads.
So appreciate
how you concisely discuss that.
Great
yeah.
And I'm happy to pick that up.
Sorry for my clumsiness here,
but this is so here we go.
In terms of the basic structure
that you will recognize.
So here's the I came at this from
what's called perceptual control theory.
I don't know if, you know, not too many.
It's underdeveloped relative
to at least in my field, clinical psych
really don't pay any attention to it.
Well, William Powers
developed perceptual control theory.
It comes off the old cybernetic tradition
and archive.
And a lot of this will feel similar.
But anyway, behavioral investment theory
then evolves
in from a perceptual control
theory model,
which I see is very, very much in line
in essentially what you're doing here.
This is the basic schematic.
I don't get in.
I'm not well versed in mathematics.
My son's a math major
who teased me all the time.
I can't even goddamn read differential
equations, which is to my shame.
But whatever it is, part of my reality.
The bottom line is
here is the basic schematic, OK?
So you get salient control variables,
you get an input transduction function,
then you're going to create
a model perception that's going to create
a valence value in structure
that's an energizing action in return.
So this basic loop is the loop
that I've been operating off of.
And basically it's an active inference
control loop in, you know,
not without getting under the hood
of the neural computational specifics
about how things are set in terms of its
sensitivity, but you can follow this
at a more sort of psychologically
higher level of organization.
So that's what I just wanted to show
is that it's
the the ground to be able investment
theory is this perception
action calibrating loop structure
that functions.
And an example in perceptual control
there is you
create an image of an ideal egg
and then you run through a bunch
of subgoals in relationship
to reducing discrepancy towards that.
You're having emotional reactions
in relationship to whether or not you're
achieving the efficiency of those goals
in expected time frames.
As long as you're not getting surprised
and in the constraints
and moving in the right direction,
you're getting jolted with positive
affect and continue the investment.
If all of a sudden, you know, you break
the egg the wrong way, you overcook it,
there's no eggs in the fridge
that can interrupt the structure,
you get a negative activation of affect,
and then that reboots a possible
new behavior investment path.
So anyway, just in terms of sort
of the basic architecture of
that structure.
That's actually a perfect short
section. So thanks for making that clear.
Let's get the active loop up
so I'll mention two points of contact
with active
and the loop that you described
and then Bleu.
So the first one is that in fact in.